hi I'm Ari and I got a hundred people at
my work to stop sucking for a week and
it made me think about how I can get
more people to stop sucking this is a
story about how I went to my state's
capital Sacramento to try and help get
Californians to stop using single-use
plastic straws but wait why five hundred
million plastic straws are used in the
US every day many of those straws end up
in the ocean and can harm Sea Life
reports predict that by 2050 there will
be more plastic in the ocean than fish
my journey starts with Sheila Moore
Avanti she's a mom in LA who was
instrumental in getting the city of
Malibu to ban straws
we found this many straws just walking
for five minutes at the beach so I went
to the city and I asked if they would
implement the ban and not only did they
vote on it unanimously banning all
plastic straws but also pasta cutlery
and stirs that's amazing awesome after
talking to Sheila I was so inspired and
I wanted to see how I could get involved
to address the problem of single-use
plastic straws so I decided to do some
research I discovered that Ian Calderon
the california state assembly leader had
created a bill called straws upon
request I called his office to ask if he
would tell me more about it and he
agreed to meet with me it's a really
easy simple bill it just says you go
into a full service dining restaurant if
you want a straw you can have it you
just have to request it so it's straws
upon request
we're not banning it but we are raising
awareness and I think it's gonna cut
down on the prevalence of straws how do
you think people can get involved the
best type of advocacy is always to reach
out to your elected officials so you
have Assemblymember Laura Freedman it
was amazing okay great uh and your state
senator is Kevin de Leon it depends on
what you're willing to do so you can go
into your Assembly members office you
can even write here something remember a
letter or you can call it that's what
you can do locally yeah the next thing
is you got a flat second minute oh I
want to try and come
I'm gonna undo a public comment when
this goes before I but they have you
there that's really cool and then you
feel like that makes a difference some
people show up 100 percent
not to get on the plane to Sacramento oh
I've just arrived I feel like I'm on
Parks and Rec so I'm a little nervous
can you give me any advice thank you so
much Sheila we're going to be presenting
the bail at the Natural Resources
Committee and if it passes it'll move
along to the California Senate she's
gonna be a witness and I don't testify
are you nervous I mean not really cause
it's something that needs to be done so
she's just got to do it all right
welcome everyone to start us off is mr.
Calderon and the reason why I'm doing
this bill is because we have an issue
with single-use plastics I learned about
the problem that plastic pollution poses
to our ocean as a volunteer teen
conservation leader at the Monterey Bay
Aquarium and decided to take action for
my girl-scout cold war project I found a
junior and Guardians an organization
dedicated to educating people about the
problem of plastic pollution
I urge each and every one of you to vote
in favor of this common-sense
legislation and your further witnesses
in support of this bill please come
forward
hi my name is Ari Jackson and I'm here
in to testify in support of this bill
and also to show that there is strong
public support for it I'm a video
producer at BuzzFeed and I made a video
about why straws are harmful to our
environment
this video was viewed on Facebook 20
million times and it got 194 thousand
shares the top audience for this video
was Californians ages 25 to 34 the
public is very excited about this bill
and I urge you to protect the health of
our oceans and our in California thank
you thank you very much so how do you
think it went
the winners expected and I'm feeling
confident about the overall solution to
the bill I was nervous but I think it
went well no you did a really good job
it's totally normal and because it's
funny like right when you get up there
you know exactly what you're gonna say
when you're when you're going right yeah
and then you get there and it's just
like in the middle yeah
you guys all did great yeah yeah course
the straws upon request bill passed
through the Assembly floor and it is
currently waiting to be approved on the
California Senate floor if you want to
see it pass and reach Governor Brown's
desk call your representatives to tell
them you support it curbing single-use
straw use is a great start but they are
just one facet of our single use plastic
problem I believe one person can make a
difference and if you do - please sign
our pledge below to not use plastic
straws anymore
you know I still get tweets all the time
talking about how I suck because I'm
gonna put people in jail even though
it's not even in the building the
penalties were not when I played the
bill they were prescribed in my bill due
to the code section but it's okay
because it's part of the legislative
process I know that and I know
ultimately what the end result is and
it's all worth it